ich habe etwas mit mir gerungen ob ich
wirklich über dieses thema berichten
eigentlich ist es gar nicht
wissenschaftlich ist zwar absolut
spektakulär aber es ist lediglich eine
aussage zwar von stephen hawking einen
der bedeutendsten und den berühmtesten
physiker aber es ist eben nur eine
aussage keine studie wissenschaftliche
arbeit oder ein gelungenes experiment es
wird aber eben doch viel diskutiert und
irgendwann gewinnt eine nachricht an so
anfahrt dass man sie einfach behandeln
muss also diesen hawking hat gesagt in
100 jahren müssen wir die welt verlassen
ist das wirklich so ein hirngespinst
oder traurige realität jetzt wirklich
fiction herz wirkung
2117 das jahr in dem die menschheit die
welt verlassen muss aber warum nur hat
stephen hawking den klimawandel
extrapoliert und kennt jetzt die viel zu
hohen temperaturen 2017 hat er ein
atelier entdeckt der die welt
verstümmelt oder ist er plötzlich unter
die geologen gegangen und konnte den
ausbruch eines supervulkan exakt
bestimmen entwarnung nichts von alldem
stimmen zumindest trocken nichts davon
vorher gesagt allerdings hat die these
das wären 100 jahren die welt verlassen
müssen oder es zumindest sollten einen
ernsten hintergrund gerade gestern
schrieben ein zuschauer auf instagram
das web tierische angst vor einer
katastrophe habe und ich konnte ihn
beruhigen und habe ihm geschrieben und
genau das ist der punkt konkret sind wir
durch keinerlei katastrophe bedroht
es gibt allerdings wahrscheinlichkeiten
für katastrophen aber dagegen können wir
konkret auch überhaupt nicht zu sondern
müssen einfach die wissenschaft dabei
unterstützen
langfristig lösung zu finden aber wenn
jetzt ein super vulkan ausbricht ein
kamera blitz unserer erde trifft oder
und das ist am wahrscheinlichsten einer
suite unsere erde trifft dann sind wir
einfach machtlos denn wir können im
moment einfach nichts dagegen tun und
sich über etwas sorgen zu machen gegen
das darf man sowieso nichts tun kann
ja das finde ich ein bisschen vergeudete
zeit der zuschauer bedankten sich und
meinte dass er nur konkrete angst vor
einem zusammenstoß mit dem planeten nie
die ruhe habe da konstant allerdings
nochmal ganz heftig entwarnung geben
absoluter humbug und quatsch aber alle
anderen katastrophen können demnächst
oder den nächsten 100 jahren oder eben
auch später eintreffen
wir haben zum beispiel zahlreiche magma
kammer unter der erdoberfläche die in
naher zukunft den ausbruch eines super
vulkans bewirken können im weltall gibt
es ständig kammer blitze und dass wir
uns einer trifft und der so stark ist um
schäden anzurichten
das ist extrem unwahrscheinlich oder
aber aktuell da können wir inzwischen
sicher sein dass ein riesiger
gesteinsbrocken auf dem weg zur erde ist
und einen heftigen einschlag verursachen
wird der potentielle millionen menschen
töten wird aber wann das sein wird das
weiß niemand auch nicht diesen hawking
seine aussage ist
wie soll ich sagen na ja etwas
pessimistisch und was die möglichkeiten
für die menschheit angeht die erde zu
verlassen vielleicht etwas optimistisch
aber genau das ist das thema einer
dokumentation der bbc aus der das zitat
von hawking stand und achtung die damit
beworben werden wollen ein schelm wer
böses dabei denkt sie ist absolut klar
umso näher und etwas ist desto
interessanter wird es für uns und da
sagt man lieber nicht dass es vielleicht
in 1000 jahren seien sondern mehr das
ist dann eben schon in 100 jahren und
unsere enkel
die werden das vielleicht erleben never
werden wir viel bekommen bis dahin
raumschiffe gebaut haben die menschheit
einander anderen ort bringen kann
befahren werden wir vielleicht mit ein
paar astronauten auf dem mars gewesen
sein
aber allein das wird verdammt teuer
vielleicht haben wir sogar den warp
antrieb gebaut und können interstellar
reisen aber mit der gesamten menschheit
oder auch nur einem signifikanten anteil
es dürfte noch viel zu aufwendig und
teuer seien und wo hindern
so könnten wir leben ich denke ich dass
wir bis dahin so sicher einen
exoplaneten identifiziert haben sollten
auf dem wir leben könnten und was machen
wir dann mit den aktuellen bewohnern
umbringen in lager stecken also es gibt
hier noch so viele ungeklärte fragen die
wir nicht in der lage sein werden bis
dahin zu klären 100 jahre wird eine
verdammt kurze zeit
es wird also noch etwas dauern bis dahin
vielleicht nicht allzu viele
katastrophen erleben beziehungsweise sie
auch überleben allerdings müsse
derzeitigen tun damit es zumindest nicht
extrem ungemütlich auf der erde wird wir
müssen die klimakatastrophe verhindert
und wir müssen dringend daran arbeiten
den einschlag eines asteroiden zu
verhindernde bedroht wenn es konkret
beides ist technisch möglich und
bezahlbar also menschheit das sind
realistische ziele
haut rein und ihr könnt schon mal damit
anfangen und mir ein apfel aufs auge
drücken dann erfahrt ihr nämlich was
unsere erde bedroht für dem thema wird
immer wieder aktuelle dieses hier weil
ich zugeben vergesst nicht gehen auch
die glocke
damit auch wirklich nichts verpasst und
da hier gibt es alle videos mit allen
katastrophen dieser erde womöglich
drohen könnten am besten am stück
ansehen und noch besser kurz vor dem
einschlafen
dann schlafen
ich kann ich erst ein also panik gedanke
bleibt dran